وصفته مصادر اسرائيليه باليوم الاقصى على
الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه الحرب لكن
الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يؤكد بعض تفاصيل ما
حدث الا بعد ساعات الامر تعلق وفق الجيش
الاسرائيلي بمقتل تسعه ضباط وجنود واصابه
اخرين في تفجيرين منفصلين خلال معارك قطاع
غزه في الساعات ال4 الماضيه الهجوم الاول
ادى لانفجار شاحنه محمله بالذخيره وقالت
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان سته من
العسكريين قضوا بانفجار الشاحنه التي كانت
تحوي مواد متفجره معده لتدمير انفاق وذلك
في البريج وتحدثت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
عن اصابه 30 ضابطا وجنديا في تفجير
الشاحنه وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه قالت لاحقا
ان تحقيقا اوليا للجيش اكد ان تفجير شاحنه
الذخائر سببه اطلاق نار من دبابه
اسرائيليه اما التفجير الثاني فتسبب وفق
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي في مقتل خمسه من
العسكريين وكان بعبوه ناسفه بينما قالت
مصادر اسرائيليه سابقا انه استهدف مبنى
كان فيه جنود وسط قطاع
غزه